,
Christine grou. Merci d'être là
Madame Groulx, tout d'abord on
va allerqui disent qui
et Alexandre 20 ans.
Après un cégep en mode virtuel
trois sessions sur quatre,
leur nouvelle vie d'adulte
ne connaît que la pandémie.beaus
que l'on a perdues. Beaucoup
ts avec nos amis
qui auraient été nécessaires.
C'est bien beau faire des zooms
nnes un peu.
ALEXANDRA DORION- Lorsqu'on a re
du premier ministre qui a dit
qu'on allait mettrecommencer à ,
c'est comme si il y avait
une enclume qu'on déposait
sur nous.
- L'enclume Omicron. Pour eux,
- S'en aller à l'école, c'est
d'ouvrir ton laptop
et de regarder tes cours
à longueur de journée.
et tu n'as plus de routine,
c'est comme plus aucune énergie.
- Quand ça fait trois mois'as en
de tes amis c'est difficile,
faque je pense que le manque
d'échappatoire ça l'a vraiment
beaucoup créé d'anxiété
chez moi.
- Qu'est-ce qui nous reste
en ce moment c'est juste
le travail et l'école et
tous les plaisirs et les loisirs
on ne sait pas comment
les effectuer.
- Ils ont beau ne manquer
de rien et être bien entouré,
ils se sentent plus fragiles
aujourd'hui.
Tout comme Pierre-Luc Labbé,
patron de 20 personnes.
PIERRE-LUC LABBÉE prés., RHUM,
Ressources et Humains
- J'étais quelqu'un qui
a toujours travail
un niveau de pression assez
élévé. Le trouble anxieux était
quelque chose qui m'était
complètement étranger.- Pourta-r
à un psychologue pour l'aider
à traverser les deux
dernières années.
- Les stresseurs dans notretrav,
tant au niveau de gérer
une entreprise mais de gérer
des humains aussi,
pis les endroits où on pourrait
avoir une soupape pour relaxer
un peu ont été quand même
beaucoup limité dans plusieurs
cas. Les symptômes de l'anxiété
sont assez épeurants aussi puis
jusque où notre tête peut aller
au niveau de la peur.
Pis aussi un gros sentiment
de culpabilité que j'ai
développé. Quand ça m'est arrivé
au début, je me suis dit que si
j'étais quelqu'un qui n'avait
pas les moyens d'aller chercher
cela, je ne sais pas ce qui me
serait arrivé. On devient quand
même assez en détresse dans des
pics d'anxiété pis de pas être
capable d'aller chercher
de l'aide très immédiatement
pour moi aurait pu être plus
grave définitivement.
- Carole Mari, elle, est mère
de trois ados et cheffe
de projet en informatique.
CAROLE MARI, cheffe de projets
en informatique- Je souffre de x
depuis plusieurs années donc
j'ai des outils. Mais là je suis
vraiment arrivée au bout
de mes rs,
je sens que j'ai beaucoup
moins de résilience et je sens
que je n'arrive plus à m'adapter
à ce qui m'est demandé.
Allô M, je termine un
petit dossier donne-moi encore
quelques minutes et je suis à
toi. Il y a quelque chose au
moi qui dimoi qui dimoi qui dim?
Je suis rendu à ma 3e dose,
j'ai respecté toutes
les consignes pis on est encores
vacciné, mais le plus confiné
aussi. Donc en fait je vous
dirai que l'effet c'est cetteese
résignation qui monte
à l'intérieur de moi,
qui provoque du cynisme,qui proe
je rêve en gris.
- La santé mentale selon elle,
a été trop longtemps négligée
dans cette crise.
- Je sens qu'il y a des choses
qui se mettent en place, j'ai vu
qu'il y a des restaurants
allaient ré-ouvrir, mais
je me demande si c'est pas
un peu tard. Si moi avec tous
les outils que j'ai réussi
à développer à travers un suivi
psychiatrique, psychologique
je me sens comme ça, j'ose pasin
des citoyens doit se sentir.
- Consulter un psychologue
ou un psychiatre au Québec
est devenu très difficile même
au privé. Au public, les temps
d'attente peuvent aller
jusqu'à deux ans.
Caroline Thomassin-Girard
est pédopsychiatre.
Dre CAROLINE THOMASSIN-GIRARD
pédopsychiatre
- La liste d'attente elle est
très très longue. Actuellement
on a dû la suspendre.
On ne peut plus accepter de
nouveaux patients parce que
les délais étaient trop longs.
D'une part puis d'autre part,
le phénomène qui se passec'est s
reviennent beaucoup aussi.
- Elle constate à quel point
la pandémie frappe les jeunes 1.
- Ca été beaucoup beaucoup les
troubles anxieux. Beaucoup les
troubles relationnels aussi
parce que un enfant c'est
difficile à sortir de son
milieu. On parle de détresse des
enfants mais les familles sont
en détresse, les parents sont en
détresse, les profs sont en
détresse faque tout est
fragilisé autour des jeunes donc
il y a beaucoup d'enjeux
relationnels.
- "Il faut briser leur
isolement", dit-elle, lutter
contre le découragement
et rester optimiste.
- J'ai le goût de dire que
je ne suis pas inquiète.
J'ai le goût de dire que je suis
touchée que ça me fait beaucoup
de peine de les voir traverser
toutes ces épreuve
Mais j'ai goût de dire aussi
que je pense qu'ils vont
développer autres choses
pis je p
vont développer d'autre chose.
- Tous rêvent de passer à autre
chose pour aller mieux.
- Les éq
Québec ont besoin de se
rassembler et de retrouver une
culture d'entreprise et pouvoir
travailler ensemble.
ère au bout
du tunnel. Je crois que l'on
n'a pas le choix de garder
espoir.
- Il y a un besoin de santécess.
Je pense que les gens ont besoin
de continuer à vivre.
- Je trouve que maintenant
il est temps qu'on apprenne àecà
assumer un certain niveau de
risque. Ça va bien aller,
mais tu sais: ça v